holy cow people
it looks like we made it and 2020 is
officially coming to a close
and lordy it was definitely one for the
record books
while so many people went completely
bananas this year and some for good
reason
i'm thrilled that so many of you have
shared with me how this
show has become a little oasis of sanity
for you in the desert of craziness
as traditional media rightfully
continues to implode
i'm happy to tell you guys that the
reuben report is continuing to grow and
trailblaze
in this new digital landscape we
expanded our partnership with blaze tv
launched my weekday direct message live
streams and reached more people than
ever during this election cycle
and of course we did a couple of tequila
shots along the way
for the last week of 2020 i wanted to
look back on some of my favorite moments
from the sit-down interviews this year
we had a ton of incredible guests on the
show from senators ted cruz and rand
paul to new media superstars ben shapiro
and candice owens
to all-star comedians brian callan and
nicole arbour
i promise to continue having the
conversations that matter as we roll
into 2021
barring a full-blown zombie apocalypse
in which case i'll be hiding in a bunker
and it might take a little time
to get internet down there but i think
that goes without saying so now enjoy
this look back at some of my favorite
moments on the reuben report
from 2020. about a week later and now
that now i have was off the grid already
i was uh in the fruit section i was
buying a melon actually
i do enjoy a little watermelon in the in
the summer months it gets hot here
and uh and there was a woman likes like
screaming
in joy uh about kamala harris so i
suspect
that it is kamala harris i'm guessing
it's kamala harris the way you're
nodding at me sort of
it is kamala harris she is the worst she
is the worst she is the worst
i mean she is the worst do you think she
is the worst do you think
would have helped him or hurt him in the
polls do i think that kamala would help
him or hurt him
well it can't really well first off the
polls at this point it's like who knows
what the polls mean it can't really help
because the democrats hated her nobody
voted for her nobody likes her
and and the the crazy lefties that are
running the show right now the anti-fa
bernie coalition of marxist lunatics
they all hate kamala harris because they
think she's like a corporatist
sellout but she that's so gross
it's so gross and it did you know look
she's the worst she's the worst
kind of authoritarian yeah you remember
that moment at one of the debates when
she was still in it
when the question was asked to uh biden
about would you use an executive action
to ban
assault weapons or do something on guns
yeah and biden said
people can find this biden said oh it
would have to be constitutional
and kamala harris looks at him laughing
and she says
joe can't we just say yes we can
and it's like wait a minute you think
that you can use the power of the
executive branch to supersede the power
of the legislative
branch on something that's enshrined in
the constitution
yeah like she's the worst oh it's funny
you mentioned that
witchy cackle because you'll remember
this is the big problem when biden picks
her
uh she launched the most vicious attack
against biden that has yet been launched
this cycle she she called him a vicious
racist
at those early debates and said he was a
segregationist or whatever right oh
right
remember that the business and all this
thing so
she goes on the colbert show and colbert
to his credit pushes her he says uh
uh senator harris what happened to joe
biden being a terrible racist
and she she puts on the cackle she goes
it was a debate and so he says right it
was a debate but
but you know are you saying you were
lying then or it's not because
hahaha it was a debate it was a debate
it's called a debate it was a debate she
must have repeated the one
that's how evil these people are that
that's what i'm talking about
yeah it's all becoming too obvious to
him yes
yeah the the nonsense she never believed
he was a racist no one in their right
mind believes joe biden is a racist
but then you throw it out there and it
and and for anyone that's on the fence
about politics that's that's watching
this happen
it's like when you see them do it
against their own and it's a lie does it
make you wonder when they call everybody
else maybe it's a lie too
right let's just talk about the world as
it is
at the moment for justice do you believe
on this show oh you can curse your
brains out but but what do you mean
you're you're a you don't curse
i know but i do if you promise me i'll
believe that then i'll curse oh
i yes my people will bleep it yeah
i've been waiting for that for a long
time shapiro because i've heard you say
[ __ ] off my guys don't have to bleep my
[ __ ] they can bleep your face yeah
that's
[ __ ] privately and then you you put your
little as you know as you know there is
a bit of a gap between the public
persona and
private curse of blue streak because you
know so that's not that's not a great
shock but yes okay so yeah
let's let's just do it for a little bit
uh are we [ __ ] like what the hell is
going on here right now um
it feels that way i mean it really does
feel as though any common bonds that we
once shared are basically
disintegrating and that you're being
pressured into mimicking the belief that
all those bonds are gone
so even if you believe that the bonds
aren't really frayed and that really we
should have some stuff in common
if you say that out loud you're part of
the system you're part of the white
supremacist system
and this is it's such dangerous stuff
and as we're sitting here very
in the last few hours there was a there
was a sort of graphic that came out from
the national
museum of african american history and
culture which is a smithsonian institute
taxpayer-funded institution by the
government funded by the government
uh and it was all about whiteness and
the evil's whiteness and among the evils
of whiteness things that we have all
integrated into our lives because
of the prevailing system of white
supremacy where things like hard work
individualism justice time management
delayed gratification science i'm not
kidding this is all in the document
these are all these are all things that
are listed
as elements of white supremacy that must
be rejected in order to move forward
into a better more progressive world and
so all the things that you would think
like yeah i feel like we should all have
this in common like you know science
this one this one we should have in
common there's a whole movement to say
no no all of these things are outgrowths
of an evil
system and that in turn is a the result
of an absolutely despicable redefinition
of the term racism for what it used to
mean in
for virtually all of human history but
certainly since the 1960s
to what it means now so in the 1960s
racism was what we all think of racism
as
believing in the inferiority or
superiority of a particular racial group
right very easy definition you can spot
it wherever you see it right
it's not not hard it's very easily
applied definition and then
there's been an attempt in the last
several years to redefine racism to mean
any system that results in racial
inequality
is itself racist and so if you are not
seeking the destruction of that system
you are complicit in racism and in order
to be anti-racism you have to seek to
destroy that system well
every system in human history has
resulted in inequality of some sort or
another because human beings
have different capacities we make
different choices if you literally you
tell me we're not
all exactly the same we don't have all
the exact same thoughts and gifts and
skills you're telling me
stop being racist stop it stop it so
it's slightly different
abram kenzie specifically writes this
right and how to be an anti-racist he
says literally any system
that generates racial inequality is a
racist system and
so therefore it's not like you're a bad
person because you're a racist you're
just a product of the system or you're
upholding the system
and in order for us to fight that racism
we have to fight the system itself
and so anything that is part of that
system anything and everything that is
of that system
is tainted by racism and must be ripped
down
completely and if you are complicit in
the system by by doing things like hard
work and individualism you're an
assimilationist right this is what is
what everyone kenzie says and how to be
an anti-racist and robin d'angelo sort
of mirrors this
and you're saying yourself wait a second
are you closing in an awful lot of doors
to black americans and minority
americans like the pathways to success
in a free system are things like hard
work individual effort
you know thinking ahead delayed
gratification like this is not unique to
capitalism or the evil american system
or anything right but also what are you
saying about black people
it's insane i mean david duke could
write this [ __ ] right i mean he really
could i mean david duke could write the
idea that whiteness
is about hard work and individual
initiative
and religious adherence and family
structure right that's crap david duke
would write yeah but the anti-racists
are writing the exact same crap and
they're saying yeah but all those things
are bad right and if we just got rid of
our adherence to these systems well then
we wouldn't really have to have
standards that we hold people to
and then equality would be the result i
mean that's insanely dangerous stuff but
because the charge of racism is the most
is the most highly charged charge you
can make against somebody it's the worst
thing you can call somebody in america
and for good reason because
that is an awful thing to be right it's
an awful thing to say about somebody
it's an awful thing to be
because that is such a highly loaded
term
it's so easy to cudgel people into line
all you have to do is just
acquiesce all you have to do is be the
person who cheers on the guillotines as
the guillotines chop off heads
and we'll leave you alone now we're not
going to say that you're left alone
forever right
this only holds true until the time for
the next guillotine what was it like for
you to
sort of be someone that was supposed to
be talking about the news
but also for a lot of the time you were
you were kind of making news i mean
everyone knows the
what happened with trump and and the the
debate
um but that you sort of got sucked into
news too
and in in the movie there's a line where
um nicole kidman as as you basically
says that you know no no charlize theron
oh sorry uh charlie's thrown where she
says um
you know that she you basically saying
you know
you didn't want to be making the news i
assume that's pretty i didn't want to be
the story
yeah yeah i said i'm not going to be the
story and i don't want to be the story
and and i was the story after that
debate and i
hated it and i have hated being the
story every time it's happened
you know i see journalists as as
you know on the sidelines not as players
on the field
and um you know trump to some extent
grabbed me and put me on the field
and the roger ailes thing did too and
then just i don't know once you get
well known you know that the sleazy
media
takes a big interest in you and starts
following you around and
they're not all bad some guys are good
there's actually a sweet guy
right after i left nbc all these
paparazzi were outside of my apartment
and um
you know i couldn't like leave without
getting and
this one guy he was from the post he got
his shot he's like
and then he goes this is such [ __ ]
megan you can't say anything anymore
so like there are real people out there
they're not all bad but
i don't like being the topic of the news
i
i have asked myself many times why that
keeps happening you know
i think um i think people aren't used to
seeing like
somebody they can't figure out somebody
who's sort of
unapologetically strong um especially
especially a woman that we're out there
but like
it's not that common and um
it's a woman who doesn't mind fighting
right like it's
like what what what's she doing well you
know that i'm futilistic by nature and i
think it
it may be exciting it may be upsetting
you know it may be alienating but for
whatever reason
it's attractive news yeah it's funny to
me because
as you're getting back into the fray
like it's so obvious there's going to be
a moment
like within a couple months where
something's going to happen
like you're going to say something or
one of your guests is going to say sorry
and you're going to be like oh why did i
get back in but then but then an hour
later you'll be like this is exactly why
i got back in like that's just the
negotiation
i don't think that's going to happen to
me i mean i do think they're going to
come after me you know knives out but
i'm just so used to being attacked for
everything i say it's like at this point
i'm like
all right you know what what are you
gonna do you're gonna call me a mean
name
what would that feel like what would it
feel like to see myself called something
horrible in every newspaper
in the country oh wait i've done that in
a way it's sort of empowering because
it's like
they they took their best shot i'm here
i'm well
i'm happy i'm about to launch something
that i'm really
into and for once steve like
they can't get rid of me they can't get
rid of me you know like
even if every sponsor i have is like
we're out then i'll do subscription you
know
the relationship will be between me and
my audience and they can't stop it
whether they want to or not they can't
stop it i will have my say i will have
these discussions with interesting
provocative people
people who go against the grain and if
the audience is there
i will remain on the air you're speaking
my language sister i
i may be able to retire i may be able to
retire early now that you're getting
back in
what do you mean we're going to go after
the sunset together in the digital
sunset
the digital sunset there you go so do
you miss
i mean i think i know the answer is but
do you miss sort of
the same blue dog more centrist democrat
because i think biden was the last hope
of
that thing that's what it strikes me as
and and clearly he's not going to be the
savior obviously for many reasons
but you know jordan peterson talks about
this a lot that you want this healthy
tension between the left and the right
and it's like look i i know i'm new to
the right so maybe i don't see some of
the problems that you guys have been
around so you see
but what i see is this pretty diverse
group of the real trump people the more
libertarian people
that are all that are all sort of trying
to fight for what the future is
on the left i just see purging do you
miss the old school you know i know jfk
is before your time but do you miss an
old school democrat daniel patrick
moynihan yes
look jfk is a great example scoop
jackson on foreign policy who who
believed in standing up to communists
that uh you look at jfk i i
often quote jfk you you read his
speeches for example what he says
on uh on religious liberty you read his
speeches on cutting taxes
where he campaigned in 1960 on we're
going to cut your taxes and we're going
to cut your taxes that's going to
produce more jobs
more prosperity that's going to benefit
everyone
those speeches he would be driven out of
the democratic party like some
crazy heretic today yeah
you look at the tax cut we passed in
2017.
you know how many democrats voted for in
the house
zero zero in the senate zero
there was nobody i'll give you another
example one one that
the media refused to cover but it's one
that i'm i got very passionate about
the democrats introduced a
constitutional amendment in the senate
to repeal the free speech protections of
the first amendment
now this was following the citizens
united case which citizens united has
become this totem
so hillary clinton pledged every justice
i appoint is going to repeal citizens
united
joe biden said the same thing um do they
know when they say that about what the
supreme court
nominees are going to do in the future
that that's not really how government
works
well i mean everyone does this across
the board
for democratic nominees it largely does
yeah so i've got a book that's coming
out
uh in october called one vote away and
it talks about how one vote on the
supreme court
uh can can change history are you
worried for
for a limited government guy you don't
want the administrative state to be too
big it's like
you can get in the weeds on all of this
stuff but in many ways this is what
you've spent your whole life fighting
that peop that the whole system has just
gotten so big
and crazy at this point that even if you
tell people
what's true and we have all the facts in
front of us that sort of the ship has
sailed
on on reining in the things that i think
you and i and most of my audience are
worried about
yes and no um i think if you ask your
audience obviously it's probably a very
limited government
audience but even if you ask a general
audience so for example if i ask
everybody in kentucky about whether or
not a secret court where you don't get a
lawyer should investigate political
campaigns
obviously that polls at 75 percent
particularly to keep trump out of it
donald trump's pretty popular in my
state so it doesn't hurt so much but
really if you could get trump out of it
but the problem is
people get they won't vote on principle
and idea so i didn't get any democrat
votes on this only got 11 republicans
but i got no democrats
even though many of them profess to uh
think that fisa has too much power and
shouldn't be investigating americans
they wouldn't vote for it because they
saw it as a vote
rebuking fisa over trump and so they saw
it as a political vote
but i guess i don't look at it this way
i lose a lot of time i'm i'm
and i'm used to losing and votes in the
senate
but i think most of this and this is
where we do have some ability
so we pass out a sheet of uh
prominent tweets that went out from
senators each each week on wednesday
and my office does this sheet and they
all complain because
we'll put out something and my tweet
will have gotten 30 000 retweets
and then we'll put out senator so-and-so
and they got six
so right one of the things they see is
that
the liberty movement has reach well
beyond them
and they fear the electorate these
people are afraid of elections they're
afraid of me they're afraid of
conservatives
because they're afraid someday someone's
going to wake up and challenge them in
the primary
and that's what has to happen um the
democrats
it's sort of like this democrats don't
care at all about the deficit and
they'll tell you they want to spend more
money they're honest about it
republicans say they're against debt say
they're against spending but they're
also
most of them big government republicans
vote lock step with the democrats so
really
when people ask me whose fault is it
republican or democrat i say
yeah you know it's really both parties
fault
but you know we could give up and just
try to protect ourselves
but you know i think if we give up and
and the few good voices here go away
then really i think it goes much quicker
towards socialism it goes much quicker
towards
indebtedness and big government so i
have to be some voices there needs to be
more
i was strongly considering leaving like
i was looking at real estate i
had a whole bunch of people begging me
to come to dallas i would have had a
pretty sweet operation over there
yeah my feeling right now is i want to
stay and fight here i love
i love socal i love you know i love the
weather of course and all that but like
i've built a good life here we've got
friends i like it here it's a freaking
mess absolute mess i think you're in a
bit of a similar
situation i am and i i didn't think
about staying and fighting until i spoke
to you
and i haven't stopped thinking about
that and i think you're right
um i i was just in austin looking at
property
and boy does that no i know we probably
i told you we're probably looking at the
same houses i'm on truly like man when i
could get in austin
i can save it's cheaper to live it's
that you know i don't pay that 13
tax or whatever it is or 18 um so yeah i
could save a lot of money
and um what's happening in california it
seems is businesses are leaving for just
that reason because it's very expensive
to do business here what california has
going for it is a very diversified
economy
and amazing weather um and it's just a
huge important state for a lot of
reasons but california was the state
that worked
and we have a democratic super majority
and uh if you look at local politics
it's
it's just anytime you have a super
majority of any
group i don't care if it's republican or
democrat i don't think that's good for
democracy
um your vote if you are someone who
leans even a little bit right doesn't
count
save it stay home we don't care and you
aren't getting elected to local office
you're not getting elected to to
government office
you're not unless you are pro-big union
across the board
good luck good luck otherwise and i'm a
member of a union i'm in sag
so i i understand the value of unions
but
it's expensive to do business and unless
you can
push back a little bit or come up with a
compromise i don't
i don't i'm not bullish on california
and that ain't me i've talked to some
very smart people who are economic
animals and all of them agree and all of
them are looking to get out because
it's too expensive why why i live in
on skid row basically i'm in venice i've
been in venice for 25 years i love it
but i don't recognize my town anymore as
much
and you know it's gotten really bad over
there right it's not just gotten very
bad it's become profitable
because developers now can get these
government contracts i mean
i can build you i can build you a bunch
of apartments for 200 million dollars on
prime real estate
on a parking lot and on the beach if
you'd like i'd be happy to do that and
we can just have we can create a
homeless uh
apartments people for for people who are
homeless and uh
don't worry about doing drugs or
anything else we're not gonna put any of
those restrictions on
you can come and go as you like you know
so so
there is something that see this is not
me but a scholar i had a long
conversation with called the
the homeless industrial complex once
there's money
in bidding and getting
uh homeless shelters for big developers
you better be careful so these people
need to be put in treatment
the majority of the people on the street
is not a housing problem
it's not a housing problem it's not a
housing problem it is a
mental health and addiction problem and
until we get serious about that
uh we're we're going to be in big
trouble is it weird to you watching it
spread in different areas so venice
always had a certain amount of that now
it's definitely more but like hollywood
which also always had a certain amount
it's like kind of taking over hollywood
if you just go to straight up
especially now where there aren't as
many other people on the streets now it
just seems like all there
are kind of like transient people and
homeless and tents and
well you you and as that inches closer
to west hollywood now it
it'll lynch closer to beverly hills and
that that then is oh my gosh that then
it gets pushed yeah well you know they
have their own police force but yeah
prop 47 and you can't it's not
criminalized they're all
these i voted for pro 47 because the way
it was phrased
and it had it had the again on the
ballot
as i'm voting i went well this makes
sense i don't want kids to be in a
revolving door of crime
and and police chiefs back it and did
you read the whole thing
i didn't that's it i didn't have time
remiss but that's how they get you in
this state i think more than any other
during the last election there was this
one thing on the ballot
about um you know do you want it it was
something like this do you want to put
500 million dollar
uh into education for you know blah blah
blah
and then there's essay just a giant
crazy essay on the whole thing and i
skipped all the way to the bottom
and on the bottom it says this can only
be repealed or reversed
by popular vote but nobody ever
says okay now we'll take the money from
the kids
but that's government 101 that's right
you sell it exactly the packaging thing
you're talking about
away nobody reads the fine print and
then you throw it back on the people to
be like oh you'll have to take care of
this
deal with this it does feel like we're
sort of getting if this is a video game
we're getting to the big boss we're
getting to the final boss where for
for eight levels they've just ramped up
the racism racism homophobia blah blah
blah
and now we're there like this election
is it and and it almost seems to me
that all they've got to run on is that
america is racist and if they don't have
that
it's like i don't think anyone buys any
of the policies and
unfortunately just the way the media
operates right now this isn't going to
be an election about policy this is an
election about basically
racism and socialism versus capitalism
and
and freedom something like that yeah you
know it is and
and dave the thing that always strikes
me because i i watch some of the
left-leaning stuff and and god i see
this
you know never-ending clown car of of
the black liberals that come up and then
they talk about stuff so case in point
also the mccloskey situation where where
this couple was defending themselves
from from
an angry mob who had by the way broken
into private property
and on the left with with the black
pundits this somehow becomes about race
and this somehow becomes the idea of
these people um
inflicting their white supremacy on
these black protesters um number one
those those protesters are not peaceful
number two they were not all black
and number three the last time i checked
the second amendment
in the right to bear arms is for
everybody it's not just for
for white people so i'm struck when i
see these conversations how
how quickly and how easily they remove
all agency from black people in america
and from african americans
in general they all of our agency is
removed
in these conversations yeah well it's
also incredible because they try to
paint the mccloskeys as evil for
defending their property as we
as we're watching all this stuff burn
down but it's not like the mccloskeys
woke up that morning and we're like
we're gonna go shoot people
they they had those guns for a long time
it sounds like they were actually
democratic donors at least at one point
and
supported black lives matter it's not
like they were just sitting there
waiting
to start some stuff it literally showed
up at their door
and then they defended themselves so
that's actually a good transition to to
media because you're
uh you're a media what can i call you
assassin
i suppose as well you've just had it
with the with the mainstream media too
because this is the stuff they're
endlessly peddling right
well it is and and a lot of people don't
realize dave that um so i went to
columbia journalism school i got my
master's group columbia
i worked in in medium production for
years
before i decided to come out and and say
what i really thought and do all this
myself
so i know all the games dude i know
about
crafting a tweet and leaving half of the
code off
um i know what fake news is because
sometimes fake news are actually most of
the time
fake news isn't an outright lie but more
a half
truth and and so you see past all these
games when i first came out as
conservative i
one of the first friends that i lost um
got deeply offended when i told him and
not in a condescending way at all
told him that i've been working in this
at that point for about five to six
years and i know these games
and you're not media literate enough to
see this and he got deeply offended by
it and then that was
it and just like it's whatever um but
people didn't realize these games and i
think the deeper we get into this we see
it
over and over and over again and folks
like like you and i
when there is an outright lie and i mean
a
whopper it has to be shut down so quick
because if you don't then it becomes
part of the lexicon and it becomes
common knowledge
case in point of trump very fine people
comment
which has been debunked so many times
but
it is canon among the left and that's
because
and that was a feeling on the right
because they didn't shut that down
immediately
immediately when they shut up
fortunately we had suits because we were
supposed to go that night to an event
that ben shapiro was headlining and we
were supposed to be in super nothing
sorry ben we uh
we left here to go see the president we
go to mar-a-lago there's
like like an absolute insane security
situation and they have to like drive us
around a small island right miles around
the city yeah it was like crazy to get
in there we get in there
we're like basically almost strip
searched before thrown on the back of a
golf cart yeah like they really
well it's the president you know and
then as you've described it it's sort of
like the playboy mansion but like
doused in gold and hairspray although it
didn't feel cheesy at all it actually no
it
felt kind of classy or old school or
something and we go in
and there's a main dining room and i'd
say there were probably about 50 people
in the main dining room
and candace owens was there and a couple
other people that we sort of knew
and we were sort of whisked into the
side room which is i guess the more
exclusive room where there's maybe 20
people
right and our table is right in the
middle just like an extra layer of
secret services to get into that room
right and
they make sure no phones no pictures
blah blah blah our table is like
literally in the center of the room so
the four of us have a nice dinner and
sitting next to us
you know one table over is president
trump and melania
and rudy giuliani and they have two
other two or three other people there
and we have a great dinner we had a
great time right like totally fun and
don doesn't drink
but uh and when some one funny thing was
happening but somehow the way we were
sitting
i kept drinking your your wine so
basically i had like seven glasses i was
like obviously
over by the end yeah and i was yeah
figure out why until i realized what was
happening it's because you're a lefty
which oh that's what it was you see what
i did here
actually today because this isn't a real
shoot yeah i let you have your water on
your left side
normally i make the water on that side
and then the people say i lost
over there they say i lost all my lefty
cred look at that um
anyway then at the end of the meal
junior says he's gonna take some of your
water go crazy
uh junior says hey do you want to meet
my dad i was like all right let's meet
your dad
so we go up to him and and remember this
is like two or three days after
impeachment had just been announced
which feels like another lifetime ago at
this point
and everyone every story was about trump
is freaking out the walls are closing in
he's a paranoid lunatic the guy's
sitting there he had no tie on he looked
totally relaxed his hair was a little
more disheveled than usual
he was having a ball he was laughing if
you were living on the moon
you didn't know who donald trump was he
didn't know who the president united
states was and all of a sudden you found
yourself in this room and they said to
you
the president of the united states is in
this room who do you think it is
i guarantee you you would never think it
was him right this guy was sitting there
pretty quiet
yeah for the most of dinner just
listening to other people listening to
his wife speak mostly actually
and was i was expecting this like loud
bombastic
blowhard sort of like not nothing even
against him it's just i think everyone
can agree like he's
you would think he's this it would be
the center of attention
sucking a lot of the energy out of the
room the exact opposite yeah it was it
was the reverse
so so we walk up to him and he's sitting
and don jr
introduces me and he says dad this is
dave rubin he has a great podcast
you know blah blah blah and trump looks
looked up and he's like you
i kind of recognize you and i was like
oh well uh you know i go on fox i'm on
tucker all right he says oh tucker that
must be and then he turns to you
and he goes and who are you who are you
i'm just standing there
like i don't know who are you and you go
well i'm his husband and he goes husband
husband you two are married you two are
married and then he slaps his hands on
the table
yeah and he goes he goes i want to stand
up i want to stand up and shake your
hands i think that's great i think
that's good turns to milani he's like
he's like honey
these two guys are married and he turns
to music you're two you guys are too
good-looking that's your problem you're
too good-looking
he's like i gotta shake your hand that's
fantastic that's fantastic and then he
says
he goes you know i don't give a [ __ ] you
guys
and i don't think anybody else does
either and in a very trump way and also
i don't think anybody has for 20 years
no one's given a [ __ ] for 20 years
yeah and i realized at that point i was
like oh he thinks that i think he's
probably a homophobe because i'm gay and
that's why i've been told by the media
but i'm in that moment like i i mean i
knew already he wasn't a homophobe so
i'm not thinking that but i realized
how much does that suck for him to have
to preface that
after he meets a gay couple to say you
know like you know i don't care right
like we're cool right so you left
los angeles i said goodbye to you and
you said i'm going to portland
and i said why are you going to portland
and i think you said
i need to see it for myself so you went
up to portland
yes what do you see up in portland
i slightly shot my bolt on this because
i wrote a piece for one of the papers
saying california's if california is a
failed state
and then i went to oregon
yeah yeah um portland
is some people say to me you know why do
you need to go and see this stuff for
yourself and i just think it's it's an
instinctive curiosity i have and i also
even when it is exactly what you think
it is going to be
it's still interesting you know
portland oregon was exactly what i
feared it would be but a bit worse
i was horrified by the immigration of
the city
the total destruction of all public
monuments and public buildings
the shuttering up of shops intimidation
of the citizenry
the demoralization of the citizenry uh a
homelessness problem which makes even
california's look minimal
um and the fact that the city's
basically been given over
to uh an immigrated lawlessness
i went with antifa
several nights in a row uh to
pardon the language a [ __ ]
gentrification protest
which was my first yeah that was your
first one
yeah it was yes i've heard the two
always avoided the temptation
i i quite like gentrification actually i
think i think that
houses being made nicer and neighborhood
being smarter is no bad thing but
old-fashioned view uh certainly not the
viewer of antifa in portland who
sectioned off some of the streets and
went through them in the middle of the
night
screaming at the citizens and the house
owners telling them they were all stay
on stolen land this included many black
families by the way
uh shouting at these black families
white families families of every
background
shouting at them they were on stolen
land and um
and should get out were you worried were
you worried for your own safety i mean
you were you were out there with them i
mean
people know who you are yes i was um
lucky enough in the era of mask wearing
you can cover almost your entire
face uh lawfully indeed almost
compulsively
and um uh i was uh
i mean i've been in worse places and war
zones where
there's more lawlessness than that but i
i i
it was not in a pleasant situation to be
in what is nominally a first world city
um the second night i went with them to
the protest of the ice facility where
um which was a bit hairier because they
were assaulting
the studies one the very few um federal
buildings in
the in the area uh they play a game of
cat and mouse with law enforcement
they get closer and closer to the front
of the building their aim in the past
has been to barricade in the buildings
put burning dumpster trucks in front of
them and then kill the people inside by
burning them
alive so that's their modus operandi so
you can understand why the ice officers
don't want that
and they get within a certain uh
closeness to the door
and then the uh officers break out and
uh
there was firing tear gas pepper bullets
and all that were and people were
selling fire things in the street
and uh and that was that was uh
unpleasant yes
uh i got um uh
you know shoot out of a of an alleyway
by federal officers with a bunch of
other antifa with me and um
the officers at gunpoint you know told
us please to move
out of the alleyway and it was
unpleasant but i have to say that
considering the situation i thought the
officers were as as decent and
reasonable and uh efficient in their
duties as they could possibly be
i have to read you there is a song that
is
i'll just bust out your glasses excuse
me sir
now that we're going blue so there's a
new song that's taken over the world
and when i say taken over the world i
mean like this is the story
okay this is like the story yeah so
i don't even know you know i don't go
blue on my show yeah i don't know you're
an
unbelievable guy clean clean cut i don't
wear socks in my loafers you know i try
to be
i can't say the name of this of this
song without going blue
would it be better and you're hosting
right now so i want you to do what you
think is right would it be better if
if i just read it straight up i would
feel much better if you
so the song is called whap okay
right it's like it's by cardi yeah w.a.p
okay it's by cardi b and this song i
mean this is like
now the the anthem the feminist anthem
right and cardi b
i'm not totally sure who she is but i
know she was like fighting with people
right before i went
yes she she supported bernie sanders
she's got long nails i think she and i
think that's racist for you to say that
but yes she does
so have long skills is this song's just
taken over everyone's this is everyone's
taken over
so i'll just i guess i'll just read a
little yeah [ __ ] in this house
there's some [ __ ] in this house
there's some [ __ ] in this house
there's some [ __ ] in this house hole
up i said certified freak
seven days a week wet ass [ __ ] make
that pull out game weak
that's good yeah and then the chorus
yeah yeah yeah
yeah you [ __ ] with some sweet ass
[ __ ] bring a bucket and mop
for this [ __ ] mop for this oh
bring a bucket and mop for this you got
to mop up
give me everything you got for this wet
ass [ __ ]
uh i'm going to not do the next
paragraph because that's where they'll
come for me
yeah this is the so so where does she
get her mop
yeah you can't it's got some words that
you're not allowed you know yeah yeah
so that song i mean she's making a point
it's not she's making not without merit
no it's not it actually i
th the song actually does have a point
the thesis of the song
okay is that all women
are prostitutes that's actually the
thesis she says yeah i got my man by
and she describes sexual acts that i
know look we're young hit millennials
okay we've done also
like that you've never thought of i mean
in this kind of
it's i didn't know that pornography
having a slot bucket
it's like just that image not only i
didn't know that
that audio could be pornographic i
thought pornography is only visual yeah
so she's saying that these things are
good like this is how you attain power
in essence it's not yes it's right
she's not which is so the root it's so
the reverse
actually of what what at least first
wave feminism was all
yeah yeah it's it's a it's funny because
it's such a ridiculous song but it is a
commentary on our map
whap i see and it then it hits you it
took me like a day to i thought oh
as i'm pondering this deep song of great
scenes yeah
and but that's it that and the so to say
that
calling women prostitutes and having
them sell themselves is empowering
is is obviously a complete reversal of
reality like you say reality is on trial
it's emblematic to me of everything
that's going on you really do do it
through comedy like if you want to tell
people the truth and not get punched in
the face
you got to do it through comedy right
that's uh that's just kind of the way
you got to do it and that
you really have mastered that but i'm
curious did you
were you kind of right before then
because i want to get to when you kind
of came out for trump
but were you always we both had our kids
yeah yeah we had kind of similar events
yeah
yeah yeah but but like what were you
before did you
did you consider yourself liberal
conservative blah blah blah
so liberal this is my liberal sweater by
the way at least liberal media
okay this is like freaking cnn reporters
all over it
um yeah 100 liberal for sure for sure
and then
i actually had a good friend in la i was
staying at her house and we were
watching
cnn or something before the last
election and she's like you know
me and my whole family vote for trump
and i thought
she's a crazy person and i literally
thought i probably can't be friends with
this person anymore that means she's
evil she's
a bad human like i was like are you guys
like racist
knowing her boyfriend is a black man i
thought it was weird
and eventually i realized oh no her
family just owns a bunch of businesses
and employs a lot of people
oh okay that makes sense for them why
they would support him and then
i started to see the unraveling of all
the things i've been taught you go to
enough parties in hollywood you learn
they're all douchebags
it's just it is what it is
98 you know the ones who live in texas
most of the time they're pretty dope
um yeah but i i started seeing that
every single thing that these people
pretend they are
they are actually the polar opposite and
i went well
what's the opposite of [ __ ] i kind of
want to go that way
and i saw i caught you know even jimmy
kimmel i caught him multiple times
lying in stories yeah total lie and i
actually was responsible for outing him
twice
he probably hates me in the last year
because i was like wait a minute
that doesn't seem right i'd go to c-span
and watch the full
uncut footage and then i'd do a quick
video on it and be like
jimmy kimmel did you just lie to your
entire audience
let's see and he did and then he issued
an apology a couple days later on
twitter
um he was lying about mike pence and one
of them
but the more i saw this the more i was
like [ __ ] tricked me
you tricked me doesn't it doesn't it
seem crazy to you that
you have to like fact check comedians
as a comedian like if you would have
said that to any any like eight-year-old
who wants to be a comedian and your job
will be to fact-check comedians through
comedy
you'd be like what the f are you talking
about
right you can swear with me it's okay i
saw you tell ben shapiro to swear i've
told him to swear multiple times too i
was
i was being hosti there but i would like
ben to say yes
yeah same just like just once and then
we can put it on a loop and turn it to
song
exactly yeah often think now now that
i've been taking some of these positions
that aren't thought of as popular or
or okayed by mainstream or whatever that
the only thing to fear is fear itself
and i've been thinking about that a lot
lately that
the more that i say the things that i
believe to be true that happen to be
against the mainstream things
the more i get over that because if you
can get over the fear
then if it's true that we're on a list
and they're coming for us
then we're on a list then we're on a
list and by the way pretty much
everyone's on the list and that's why
there's that famous thing
you know they came for the jews first
it's like we're all we're all part of
this thing
but it's a very strange time that you
can show me some of these things
founding documents from the united
states documents about saving jews
during world war ii and it feels like
something that's kinda now
only if people don't find their courage
yeah i truly believe and this is why i
think you're so powerful
courage is contagious it is people not
everybody's
a leader not everybody's willing to step
out
into danger you know not everybody's
willing to lose all their friends or to
whatever but when they see someone
risk everything and they see them
on a list if you can get them early
enough
they'll step out but the longer you wait
the worse it gets that's bonhoeffer was
a pacifist was involved
in vod staffenberg's uh coup
how he's a pacifist he
he said there's nothing else we can do
at this point because it's too late
the people's hearts had turned to stone
and you couldn't turn them
we have to find a way to make sure that
our hearts and the hearts of everybody
we know
stay soft and see people as people
not enemies you know when i was on tour
with jordan one of the things that he
would bring up often because he would
talk about the parallels to
nazism to some of the authoritarian
movements of the day and he would say to
everyone in the crowd he'd say
you know there's 3 000 of you sitting
out here right now
and i guarantee you that every single
one of you
would think that you wouldn't be a nazi
if this was 1936 germany
and that proves probably that you would
be
and i always thought that that was
pretty powerful we all think we would do
the unpopular thing we all think we
would do the risky thing we all judge
everybody by our standards of today
i'm not sure i'd stand in the end
i mean a friend of mine marcus
trell i said to him
how do you stand torture and not break
and he said glenn everyone breaks
everyone breaks he said
but the ones who break the fastest and
the loudest
are the ones who will say i'm never i'll
stand
oh i'll stand because they haven't
thought about it it's why i wanted to
bring my kids to auschwitz i need you to
feel it so you can think about it and
really look at this
as a possibility and once you do that
and you realize by the grace of god i'll
stand
um then you're then you're ready
but we we have got to prepare ourselves
now to be ready because if you're ready
now the problems go away
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell